so yesterday we got the Avengers for
prelude comic there was a lot of hype
around this because we didn't know if it
was going to reveal the title or
anything about the movie at all
everybody seemed to believe that we were
going to get something but we didn't
really get anything weird we're a time
bomb you need to step away now normally
they have the title but normally the
title is already out and we don't have
the title yet we don't really have
anything yet as you can see here the
title is just Avengers Prelude now this
is one of three but this particular
prelude part one is really just a recap
of Avengers infinity war well a recap of
the first quarter of Avengers infinity
war so I'm gonna do a breakdown of the
prelude but just as a heads-up there's
nothing about Avengers 4 in here and I
do think they did that on purpose
because they knew this would come out
around the time that the trailer came
out but there is a part two and a part
three coming so I'm hoping those will
include some scenes that were not an
Avengers infinity war ok so this starts
off just like the movie
Thanos on Thor ship he just killed half
the Asgardians the other half escaped
danos gives his speech about destiny
arriving he has Thor by the head and
he's talking to Loki saying give me the
tesseract or I'll kill your brother Loki
says kill away and Thanos starts to use
the Power Stone on Thor but of course we
know Loki stops him and pulls out the
tesseract we then get the famous line we
have a Hulk then Thanos and the Hulk
fight and we know how that ends but what
is interesting about this comic strip is
that the Power Stone is actually lit up
inside of the gauntlet my initial
reaction is well Fanus is simply using
the Power Stone to defeat the Hulk I
mean it's the Hulk but in a recent Q&A
with the Russo brothers they confirm
that Thanos didn't actually use the
Power Stone to defeat the Hulk
he simply outsmarted him so it's very
curious that they have it glowing in the
scene then of course Thor runs to his
aid but can't do anything against Thanos
and then ebony maw holds him down with
the metal Heimdall calls for powers from
the all fathers one last time to send
the Hulk to earth and then of course
Thanos kills him then Thor tells Thanos
you're going to die for that
Kreacher he doesn't say mad creature in
the movie and it's worth noting that he
doesn't say mad Titan
he says mad creature this sort of
implies that he doesn't really know who
Thinnes is Thor has a mass amount of
knowledge about the Infinity stones
because of the events of Avengers age of
Ultron he sets off to learn more about
the Infinity stones but Thor gets his
knowledge about Thanos from Gamora when
the guardians of the galaxy pick him up
then we have the scene where ebony MA
praises Thanos and gives him the
tesseract then danis breaks the
tesseract and takes the space stone and
puts it in the gauntlet then right after
that one of our favorites Loki comes out
and tries to trick Thanos and attempts
to kill him of course
Thanos knows what's coming and ends up
killing Loki as far as we're concerned
so far at least
and then Thanos uses the Power Stone to
destroy the rest of Thor's ship and uses
the space stone to get himself and the
children of Thanos out of there so just
like the movie we cut to the next scene
which is the Hulk falling into the New
York sanctum sanctorum the Hulk crashes
in and says Thanos is coming but what's
interesting about the comic is that he
says a little bit more he again says
Thanos he's coming for the stones we
need to find Tony Stark now this is why
these preludes are pretty cool because
you get a little bit more from them
little tidbits here and there that you
didn't get in the movie we then cut
right to the scene where Wong is
explaining to Tony Stark and Bruce
Banner what the Infinity stones are Tony
says Pepper sure ain't gonna love me
ditching out on her for this this is a
line that was not in the movie but what
this means is that Tony knows how big
this is this is what he's been fearing
since the first Avengers movie in New
York he said Loki the attack on New York
that's him
Bruce tells Tony that he's got to
assemble the Avengers but Tony explains
to Bruce that the Avengers are kind of
broken up right now Banner tries to
explain to Tony that Thor is gone
banner believes that Thor is dead and it
doesn't matter if the Avengers are
broken up or not they're going to need
everybody but as he's explaining this
they start to hear noise outside which
is of course
evany MA and Cole obsidian ship they
then go outside in which they encounter
evany MA and call obsidian then Tony
asked banner to get the hope to come out
but what he says is a little bit
different than what he says in the movie
Tony says banner or Hulk 1 apiece and
banner replies with I'm sorry I I can't
or he won't so right here they're
clearly stating that the Hulk and banner
are two very different people much like
we learned in Thor Ragnarok the Hulk has
a mind of his own and he's done fighting
banners fights for him so that's why
banner says he won't he won't come out
it seems like they're setting it up for
a professor Hulk to come in in Avengers
4 but we'll see what the next two
prelude comics have to say about it we
then go through the same scene that we
saw an infinity war where Doctor Strange
sends Banner to the park and Tony ends
up there as well when he gets hit by
Kool obsidians Hammer spider-man ends up
showing up and saving Tony Stark but
here's where something gets really
interesting
bini mah tries to grab the eye of
agamotto which is holding the time stone
from Doctor Strange and he burns his
hand but what Doctor Strange says here
is different than what he says in the
movie he says it's a simple spell
binding the stone to me but quite
unbreakable they add the binding the
stone to me in this prelude comic it's
not in the movie you may have caught my
video on the theory that dr. strange
actually cursed the time stone well this
could further back that theory because
he didn't say that he put a curse on the
eye of agamotto he said that it's a
simple spell binding the stone to me
so perhaps dr. strange really did curse
the time stone and that's why he gave it
up to Thanos so easily we'll have to
wait and see on that one so the next few
strips are exactly like they are in the
movie a Bini mod takes Doctor Strange
and Iron Man send spider-man after him
Wong ends up showing up and saves Tony
from coal obsidian and then spider-man
ends up stuck on ebony mashup in which
Iron Man goes after him a Spider Man
begins to run out of
air and falls from the ship iron man
hits him with his new iron spider suit
that was such an amazing scene in the
movie and it looks just as amazing in
the comic strip as well
[Music]
smells like a new car new Tony sends him
home or so he thinks and then Tony
breaks his way onto the ship
spider-man is stowing away as well and
then Tony loses connection with pepper
and his AI Friday the last scene in this
trip is banner talking to Wang saying
that he's gonna make a call we then go
to the guardians of the galaxy running
into Thor in space the next few strips
are literally word-for-word just like
they are in the movie the Guardians wake
Thor up and Thor explains that Thanos
came and obliterated his ship Gamora
explains Thanos as history and that he's
going to collect all of the Infinity
stones and then Thor and quill get into
a fight of testosterone no you're not
you will not be taking our pod today sir
well are you making your voice deeper he
just did it again
this is my voice you mocking me Thor
explains that Thanos is going to nowhere
to collect a reality stone Thanos is
going to nowhere because there are six
Infinity stones and Thanos already has
two of them the space stone in the Power
Stone Thor continues to explain that the
time and the mine stone are on earth
with the Avengers and nobody knows where
the soul stone is therefore danos must
be going after the reality stone which
means he's going to nowhere after the
conversation with Thor the guardians of
the galaxy split up rocket and Groot go
with Thor and then quill Gamora Drax and
mantas go to know where Thor rocket and
Groot go to net a Valier to collect
Stormbreaker and the rest of the
guardians of the galaxy go to nowhere to
try and stop that us and then we cut to
Wanda and vision in the last scene in
Scotland after the events of Civil War
Wanda and vis developed a relationship
together and have been sneaking off
randomly at time so they could be
together
remember that Wanda is technically a
fugitive right now and is wanted by the
United Nations so this scene is just
like it is in the movie as well they're
talking about not going back to the rest
of the Avengers and staying together
because their relationship works then
vision feels the stone and he says it's
as if it's speaking to me tell me what
you feel and Wanda says I just fill you
and that's when they see the news on the
TV in the background where the reporter
says that there's been a spaceship that
has touched down in man
hatton and that there have been several
Avengers on site and now Ironman is
missing and that's when Proxima midnight
and Corvus glaive show up and stabbed
vision in the back all the way through
the chest which stops him from
completely phasing and makes his systems
fail one two fights back and tries to
get away with her envision but Proxima
midnight shoots her out of the sky with
her spear this is where vision then
tells Wanda - please leave but she says
you asked me to stay I'm staying and
that's where it ends so as you can see
this was just a recap of all the events
that took place in the first quarter of
Avengers infinity war and it really
isn't any different than the movie there
were a few things that I picked up on
that they put in the comic strip that
weren't in the movie but besides that it
was pretty much completely the same and
this was probably done intentionally
knowing that this would come out right
around the time the trailer came out and
there are two more parts to it so
hopefully in part two and part three
will get a little bit more information
and a little bit more insight into
Avengers 4 part 2 comes out on January
9th in the third part comes out on
February 20th so again this was pretty
much just a recap not really any new
information but many people asked me to
break it down so of course I did
thankfully the trailer is still set to
come out tomorrow Friday December 7th so
hopefully tomorrow we're going to learn
a lot more about Avengers 4 let me know
down below what you think the title is
going to be and don't forget to
subscribe to my channel with the
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to
Avengers 4 as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]